this was more interpretive which is hard
it's not
hard as in not fun not hard isn't hard
digging a ditch is hard teaching in an
inner city school's heart uh but it was
it was trying and not fun to put your
brain where it has to go because there
is the Lawrence Olivier try acting dear
boy thing yeah which I get and we you
know we all appreciate that to whatever
extent
but I'm the type of person where I'm I
don't know that I'm a good enough actor
to fake it I kind of have to think about
uh
and killing in my head while doing the
lines and that's not that's I I know
there are going to be people that think
that's really uncouth and why and how
dare you and what's the point of going
there but it's like that's
that's what I do to entertain you and
make that character feel believable
without actually
exactly for the love of God it's not
like I'm one of those exactly but but by
the way there are these actors who are
like I'm gonna play a junkie so I gotta
try meth I'm gonna try heroin it's like
no you [__] idiot like you don't have
to do that but but you know what you
could do is befriend somebody who did do
those drugs and get some information
sleep on the floor for five six days and
malnourish yourself and do some of the
stuff that the junkies do and you'll be
good right as rain yeah can you have fun
on set while you're doing a part like
this or are you method a thousand
percent you have to have fun so you can
like cut and you're like anyway so uh
the other day yes but it's also not that
I'm not that brilliantly ambidextrous
like if I'm doing a really hard scene
that involves a certain amount of
uh uh mental gymnastics emotionally
verbally whatever I will
go off and I I won't I won't flaunt it
um but I will go off in a corner
in a sound stage with earbuds in and I
will you know listen to the National or
something and and
get myself in the place I gotta be
EP
[Music]
guys always drinking wine isn't he I
think so